as a scientist I'm also trained to give
more credibility to objective arguments
that and there are things that can be
reproduced things that I can demonstrate
that I can show
but as I get older there we go as I get
more mature hopefully you know
I'm starting to question why I am not
giving as much
credibility to my subjective
understanding of the world the kind of
the first person perspective when
actually modern science has already sold
on that you know quantum mechanics
has shown unambiguously that the
Observer is always involved in the
observation
likewise yodel's incompleteness
ethereums to me
shows how essential
is the Observer of a mathematical theory
for one thing that's the one who chooses
the axioms yes and we can talk about
this in more detail likewise Einstein's
relativity where
time is relative to The Observer for
instance that's brilliant you're just
describing in all of these different
scales The Observer what they observe so
we science of 19th century had the
from Modern perspective and I don't want
to offend anybody I had the delusion
that somehow you could analyze the world
being completely detached from it we now
know after the The Landmark achievements
of the first half of the 20th century
that this is nonsense that is simply not
true and this has been experimentally
proved time and time again so to me
I'm thinking maybe it's a hint that I
should take my first person perspective
seriously as well and not just rely on
kind of objective phenomena things that
can be proved in a in a in a traditional
sort of objective Way by setting up an
experiment that can be repeated many
times maybe I fall in love in a party
you know the deepest love my of my life
Perhaps Perhaps hasn't happened yet
Perhaps I will fall in love and this but
it's Unique it's a unique event you
can't reproduce it necessarily you see
so so in that sense you see how these
things are closely connected I think
that if you if we are declaring from the
outset that all there is to life is
you know computation in the form of
neural networks or something like this
however sophisticated they might be
I think we are from the outside denying
to ourselves the possibility that yes
there is the side of me which is not
faking it yes there is a side of me
which cannot be captured by Logic and
reason and you know what another great
scientist said bless Pascal
he said the heart has its reasons of
which the reason knows nothing
and then he also said the last step of
reason is to grasp that there are
infinitely many things Beyond Reason
so interesting this was not a theologian
this was not a priest this was not a
spiritual Guru
it was a hardcore scientist who actually
developed I think one of the very first
calculators
how interesting that this guy also was
able to uh
impart on us that wisdom now you can
always say that's not the case
but why should we
from the outset
exclude this possibility that there is
something to what
he was saying that is my question I'm
not taking sides
um what I'm trying to do is to shake a
little bit the debate because most
mathematicians that I know and computer
scientists even more so they're kind of
already sold on this
um we are just you know it reminds me of
this famous Lord kelvin's quote from the
end of 19th century
uh there's some debate whether he
actually said that but never let a good
story you know stand in the way of Truth
he said physics is basically finished
All That Remains is more more precise
measurement so I find a lot of my
colleagues are happy to say
yeah everything's finished we already
got we got it we got it uh maybe little
tweaks
in the in the in our large language
models you know so now here's my
question
I'm kind of Playing devil's advocate a
little bit because I don't see the other
side
represented that much
and I'm saying okay could it be also
that if you believe in that that becomes
your reality
that you can kind of put yourself in a
box
where everything is competition and then
you start seeing things as as being such
it's confirmation bias if you will you
know this also reminds me you know I
think a good analogy is it's a friend of
mine Philippe caution told me that in
France there is this literary movement
which is called ulippo
o u l IPO
and it's a bunch of writers and
mathematicians
who create works of literature
where in which they basically impose
certain constraints
a good example of this
is a novel which is called the void or
disappearance by a writer named George
pereck
which is a 300 page novel in French
with no which never uses the letter e
which is the most used widely used
letter of the French language so in
other words he said these parameters for
himself I'm going to write a book where
I don't use this letter which is a great
you know it's a great experiment a nice
uploaded but that's what it's one thing
to do that and to kind of show his
gamesmanship if you will and and his
proclivity and his ability as a writer
but it's another thing if at the end of
writing this book when you finish the
book he would say letter e actually
doesn't exist
entry to convince us that in fact French
French language does not have that
letter simply because he was able to go
so far without using it you see so
self-imposed limitation that's how I see
it and I wonder why
we should do that do we really need do
we really feel the urge to say the world
is like that the world can be explained
this way or that way and I'm saying it
you know it's a personal question for me
because I am addicted to knowledge
myself
I you know hi my name is Edward
and I'm an always addict okay I'm being
serious I'm not being facetious up until
very recently maybe a couple years ago
I simply did not feel comfortable if I
could not say they give an answer
explanation it's like oh there has to be
some explanation and I try to
frantically search for it
just for somebody like me
I know heard you know a left Brainiac
and uh
you know
that's kind of typical typical for a
scientist or mathematician it is
incredibly hard
just to allow the possibility that it's
a mystery
and not to feel the urge
to get the answer it is incredibly hard
but it's possible and it is liberating
it's recovering as a recovering addict
to knowledge let me say
what you gain from it for instance I
understand the value of paradoxes and I
I appreciate paradoxes more and you know
to to use another philosopher uh Soren
kirkegar the Danish philosopher said uh
I think or without Paradox is like a
lover
without passion
a paltry mediocrity oh that's a good
line all right
so and you know
Niels Bohr Niels Bohr said
um in similar Vein The Great Danish also
something about that something about
Danes I think it's all started with
scramble it you know
he said the opposite of a simple truth
is a falsity
but the opposite of a great truth
is another great truth
in other words
things are not black and white you know
they're not
and they would even venture to say the
most interesting the interesting things
in life
I like that the ones which are ambiguous
it's an electron a particle or a wave
it depends how you set up an experiment
it will reveal itself as this or that
depending on how you set up an
experiment
this bottle if you project it down onto
the table
you will see more or less a square if
you project it onto wall you will see a
different shape a naive question would
be is it this or that
because we understand that it's neither
but both projections reveal something
the real different sides of it a paradox
is like that it's only paradoxical
if we if we are confined in a particular
Vision if we are wedded to a particular
point of view
it's a Harbinger if you will of a
possibility of seeing things in a more
in a in a as they are as a more
sophisticated than we thought before you
see this is such a difficult idea for
science to Grapple with that you know I
don't know how there's so many ways to
describe this but you could say maybe
that the subjective experience of the
world
from an observer is actually fundamental
but we know that our best physical
theories tells us that unambiguously in
quantum mechanics actually you know
Heisenberg I think captured the best
when he said what we observe is not
reality itself
but reality
subjected to our method of questioning
um when I talk about electrons for
instance so that there is a very
specific way in which you in which this
is realized there is a so-called
double-slit experiment right so
um for those who don't know it's you you
have a you have a screen and and you
have an emitter from which you send you
kind of shoot electrons and in between
you put another screen which has two
vertical slits parallel to each other
if we were shooting you know tennis
balls each ball would go through one
slit or another and then hit the screen
behind
this or that slid so you would have
let's say they colored they're painted
so they'll be sort of bumps or or or
spots of paint behind this or that
but that's not what happens when we
shoot electrons we see an interference
pattern as if we were actually sending a
wave so that each electron
it seems like the each electron goes
through both slits at once and then and
then has the audacity to interfere with
it with itself where at some points you
know two crests would amplify and at
some points aggress in the draft would
cancel each other
yet so that suggests okay so the
electron is a wave not so fast because
if you put a detector behind one of the
slits and you say I'm going to I'm going
to capture you
I am going to find out which lid he went
through the pattern will change and it
will look like the particles so that's a
very concrete realization of the idea
that depending on how we set up an
experiment we will see different results
and the problem the problem is that our
psyche I feel kind of lagging is lagging
behind in part because maybe our
scientists are not doing such a great
job so I take responsibility for this
that why haven't I explained this
properly you know
I I tried you know in a bunch of talks
and so on so now I'm talking about this
again
our psyche kind of lagging behind we're
still even though our science has
progressed so much from the certainty
and the determinism and and all of that
of the 19th century
our psyche is somehow still attached to
those ideas the ideas of causality of
this naive determinism that the war the
world has a bunch of billiard balls
hitching each other driven by some blind
forces you know that's not at all like
this and we've known this for over for
well for about 100 years at least you
know and you call this self-imposed
limitation it is a self-imposed
limitation when we when we pretend that
uh that for instance that this naive
ideas of 19th century
um physics are still valid and and then
start applying them to our lives and
then also derive conclusions from it and
for instance people say there is no free
will why oh because the world is just a
bunch of uh billiard balls where is the
free will but excuse me didn't you get
the memo that this has been debunked
thoroughly by the so-called quantum
mechanics which is our best scientific
theory this is not some some kind of
or some kind of you know
concoction of of a of a Madman this is
our scientific theory which has been
confirmed by experiment so we should pay
attention to that so but of course it's
not just
um self-imposed limitation unfortunately
in this case there is a big issue of
Education
so a lot of people are not aware of it
through no fault of their own because
they were never properly taught that
because our system is broken education
system is broken especially in math
and then our so where do we get them do
you get information you get information
from
our scientists who actually write
popular books and so on which is a great
you know
um great thing that they do but a lot of
scientists somehow
um when it comes to explaining the laws
of physics they are doing a fantastic
job
um talking about this phenomenon for
instance double slit experiments and
things like that but then you know
interviewed by science managers in about
three wheel and so on they revert back
to 19 19th century physics as if those
developments actually never happened so
to me this is single most
uh important sort of issue in our
Popular Science
the idea that somehow there is this
world out there but it's complete has
nothing to do with me so I can I can
reveal in the
intricacies of these particles and their
interactions
but but completely ignore what
implications this has
for my own relationship to the physical
reality to my own life you know because
it's kind of scary I guess you know but
also what are the tools
with which we can talk about the
Observer
the subjective view in reality what are
the tools of which we could talk about
rigorously talk about Free Will and
Consciousness what are the tools of
mathematics that allow that I don't
think we have those tools because we
haven't been taught properly so actually
tools are there for instance
um
I think well
here we have to
I have to say my conviction is that
everybody knows
in the heart of hearts everybody knows
that there is that there is something
ineffable there is something
mysterious and in fact you know
somehow immediately I feel that
um you know the impulse to quote
somebody on this because as if as if my
own opinion
there's a long dead expert that has been
Einstein said that he doesn't like how
see look at me I have supposedly like
this smart intelligent person
I am afraid to say it and own it myself
I have to find confirmation I have to
find an authority who agrees with me and
in fact it's not so difficult to find
because Albert Einstein literally said
the most important thing in life is the
mysterious okay he actually said that
there are some quotes which are
attributed to him which he never said
but this he did I investigated okay so
but more importantly you know
how do you feel about it
um I think that everybody knows
but
in other words he also said Einstein
imagination is more important than
knowledge okay and it's explained for
knowledge is always Limited
whereas the imagination Embraces the
entire world giving birth to Evolution
it is uh strictly speaking a real factor
in scientific research he says and he
says I am enough of an artist to follow
my intuition and Imagination that's
Albert Einstein again so and I feel the
same way to be honest if I think about
my own mathematical research
it's never linear
it's never like give me more data give
me more data give me more data Boom the
glass is full and then I come up with a
discovery no it's always it always is
always felt as a jump as a leap
and I I have actually been studying
various
examples in a history of mathematics of
some fundamental discoveries like
Discovery complex numbers like square
root of negative one
I wonder if a large language model could
actually ever come up with the idea that
square root square root of negative one
is something that is essential or
meaningful because if all the
information that you get
that all the all the knowledge that had
been accumulated up to that point tells
you that you cannot have a square root
of a negative number why because if you
had such a square root
we know that if then we would have to if
you square it you get a negative number
but we know that if you square any real
number positive or negative you will
always get a positive number so
Checkmate you know it's over square root
of negative one doesn't exist yet we
know that these numbers make sense
they're called complex numbers and in
fact quantum mechanics is based on
complex numbers they are in essential
and indispensable for quantum mechanics
could one discover that so to me that
sounds like
I discontinue it in the process of
discovery it's a jump It's a departure
it is like a child who is experimenting
is like a child who says I'm not afraid
to be an idiot everybody says the adults
are saying square root of negative
number doesn't exist but guess what I'm
going to accept it and I'm going to play
with it and I'm going to see what
happens this is literally how they were
discovered there was an Italian
mathematician astral astronomer
astrologer he was he he made money
apparently by compiling astrological
sort of readings for uh for the elite
you know of his ears this is 16th
century everyone does a gambler
all around interesting guy I'm sure we
would have an interesting conversation
with him gerolamo cardano he's all he
also invented the what's called cardan
shaft so which is an essential component
of of a car
we say in Russian so
so he wrote a book which is called uh
our ass Magna which is a great art of
algebra and he was writing solutions for
the
cubic and cortic equations
this is something that is familiar
because
it's cool we study Solutions of
quadratic equations equations of degree
two so you have x a x squared plus BX
plus C equals zero and there is a
Formula which solves it using radicals
using square roots
and cardano was trying to find a similar
formula for the cubic and quartic
equations for which which would start
with x cubed or x to the power 4 as
opposed to x squared and in the process
of solving these equations he came up
with square root of a negative number
specifically square root of -17
and he wrote that I have to forego some
mental tortures
to deal with it but I am going to accept
it and see what happens and in fact at
the end of the four at the end of the
calculation
this this this weird numbers got
canceled it kind of canceled out in the
formula appeared square root of negative
17 and its negation so they kind of
conveniently gave the right answer which
is not involve those numbers so he was
like okay
what does it mean mental tortures so you
see from the point of view
over of the of the thinking mind
it is something almost unbearable it's
almost I feel that the large language
more the computer running around large
language model trying to do that would
just explode and yet a human
mathematician was able to find the
courage and inspiration to say you know
what what is wrong why why are we so
adamant that these things don't exist
that's just our past knowledge based on
what our past knowledge is and knowledge
is limited what if we make the next step
today for us mathematicians context
numbers that we call them and not at all
mysterious the idea is simply that
you plot real numbers that is to say all
the whole numbers like 0 1 and so on to
and so on right all fractions like one
half or three halves or four over three
but then also numbers like square root
of two or Pi we plot them as points on
the real line so we draw this is a this
is one of the kind of perennial Concepts
even in a in our very poor math
curriculum at school but now imagine
that instead of one line you have a pla
you have a one axis you have a second
axis
and so you numbers now have two
coordinates X and Y and you associate to
this point with coordinates X and Y
and the number X which is a real number
plus y times square root of negative one
this is a graphical geometrical
representation of complex numbers which
is not mysterious at all now it took
another two or three hundred years for
mathematicians to figure that out but
initially it looked like a completely
crazy idea you know
uh so all it is all a complex number is
is just an experience
the real part and the imaginary part
it's just an expansion of your view of
the mathematical world the fact that you
can actually multi you can add them up
by adding um together the real parts and
imaginary parts that's easy but there is
also a formula for the product for the
multiplication which uses the fact that
square root of -1 squared is minus one
and the amazing thing is that that that
product that multiplication satisfies
the same rules the same properties that
are usual operation of multiplication
for real numbers for instance there is
an inverse for every non-zero number
that you can find like number five has
an inverse one over five
but uh one plus I also has an inverse
for instance you know that was always
there in the mathematical universe but
we humans didn't know it and here comes
along this guy who engages in the mental
torture who takes a leap off the cliff
of comfort of like mathematical
established knowledge establish
knowledge right and now obviously for
each each um sort of
fruitful leap like that they probably
were thousands of like things which went
nowhere I'm not saying that every Leap
you know it's like it's a it's a it's an
open shooting game yeah because for
example you can try to do the same with
three-dimensional space so you have
coordinates x y and z
and you can say oh uh if it's
one-dimensional we have a Bonafide
numerical system called real numbers
if it's two-dimensional which is like
you know geometrically it's just like
the stable top extended to Infinity in
all directions
these are complex numbers and we can
Define addition and multiplication and
they will satisfy the same properties as
real numbers that we're used to what
about three-dimensional space is it
possible to also Define some operation
of addition and multiplication on it so
that these operations would satisfy the
properties that we're used to and the
answer is no you can Define addition but
you can't Define multiplication for
which there would be an inverse for
instance
so there is something special about the
the plane the two-dimensional case and
by the way uh next question would be
what about four-dimensional in a
four-dimensional space you again you can
and you get what's called quaternions
discovered by an Irish mathematician
Hamilton in the 19th century
and then in in the eight dimensional
there is something similar called
octonians and that's about it so how
interesting
these structures exist in dimension one
two four and eight
which are all powers of 2.
to square this four two to the third
power is eight that's one of the bigger
mysteries in mathematics why it is so
so here's a hint that's a hint of
what's missing in our on our high school
curriculum you know the kind of the kind
of fascinating the Mysteries yes the
appreciation of the mysterious but so in
other words yes we resolved with this
one mystery that we understood that
square root of negative one
Israel is Meaningful we build a theory
to service those now to to describe
those numbers
did we find The Theory of Everything no
because we then invited other Mysteries
because we we push the we pull the whale
so to speak or you push the frontier and
then new things come get eliminated
which we couldn't see before that's how
I see the process of discovering
mathematics it's an endless Limitless
Pursuit